welcome back everybody as we all make
health a priority this year it's
important to remember that wellness
starts at home and there are things you
can do to minimize your chances of
symptoms
and common colds and the flu so welcome
back to nanny bubby
hey yeah nice to see you live
i know i haven't seen you since january
i can't believe it but it's true it's
been since january but we're back and
we're together
we are back here together happy healthy
new year and happy capricorn season i
just had to throw that i was going to
say that to you
is it your birthday and my birthday
coming up next week right
yes yeah what day is yours again the
18th how about yours
right and mine is the 17th so i know
yeah so i know that everybody is you
know in the covered mindset but the
truth is
is that you know a regular cold or flu
can hit anybody
at any time and that is still out there
so what i have for you today
is a little home remedy to help you
soothe that throat
help you you know be warm and cuddly and
help you feel better kind of a
homeopathic
recipe that helps you uh right from your
own kitchen so we're going to start with
turmeric
you know about turmeric is
anti-inflammatory which is
amazing right did you know that i do
we're going to put it back on their face
too right
uh do they oh yeah should try that it's
got good color in it so we're going to
put in about a tablespoon of turmeric
and can you get a good shot of all that
orange in that pot
right there yeah there you go you see
that yep and then we're going to use
um a same tablespoon of ginger now the
thing about ginger
is that the ginger and the turmeric i
use both the skins
on it because that's where the vitamins
and the minerals are so
if you don't have a lot of ginger and i
don't like to work with ginger as a
general rule
i will put it in the vitamix and make
cubes
and so if you have a cube and you make
ginger cubes because i put them in my
smoothies in the morning and this kind
of idea
yeah and you put them in the vitamix
with a little water with the skin to
make ice cubes out of them
so there's a tablespoon of ginger we're
going to take
um a little boop
of cayenne pepper that's how i measure
it
for a lot of cayenne pepper that's how i
measure cayenne
and then we're going to put in this
starter with three cups of filtered
water
manuka honey so rocky you've never heard
of manuka honey yes i have
so tell me what you know about it
anything i know that it's anything good
and it's healthy it's the healthiest it
is it comes from new zealand
it helps sore throats it helps with
wound healing externally
helps with acne and so if you're making
something that's supposed to be great
for your
throat and your health definitely use
the manuka honey
calls for uh two tablespoons but i
like it a little bit sweeter so we're
going to put in maybe
for that one yeah i know
do i have one for that no yeah it's not
a pizza this is not a boop poop because
this takes a long time to get out right
right so we're going to do this
and while that bruised for just a little
bit because i knew we were going to have
to take some time to have it brew for us
just a little bit and simmer up and have
all those flavors and all that good
nutrients for us
come together i think i go right ahead
get rid of that yeah why not let's talk
about
all of this citrus so you know this is
the citrus time of the year let me turn
this up
let it um and the first thing we're
going to do with our citrus is we're
going to clean it great
and good now if you don't grow your own
then
you can use and i've i've talked about
this on the show
for rocky is the food grade hydrogen
peroxide
you just take it you probably have a
chapman bottle filled with it as i do
you spray your citrus let it sit for a
little while
and then you rinse it and then i always
say look
all of the vitamin c is contained into
the skins
of this so you're going to peel your
citrus look at this
it all of that juices is just squirting
right out onto my hand
all from the skin and this is going
through the biggest
organ of your body which is your skin
your epidermis
and all of that juice from the skin the
zest
is getting on here and honestly just let
it stay there let your children peel let
your
um kids children grandchildren
we're gonna take this now we're going to
strain it well i'm not
going to smell your kitchen right now oh
i want you to come here
and smell it i regret that i was not um
that i was not in the in the studio and
i can't wait until i get
back so insane that's why we're taking
these tips in so we can all be healthy
yes exactly so i'm dripping in zested uh
juice and oils from the the
skin of the tangelo and the orange i'm
going to drink this
wow i'm jealous oh i know
that's hot and maybe there was a little
bit too much
of the kayak but i'll tell you if i were
cuddled up
watching you know the food network with
a sore throat a runny nose
this would be amazing so i wish you all
the very best
in 2021 and let's only have normal
flu and cold absolutely thank you so
much nanny bubby that
bottoms up right thank you rocky you too
and happy birthday
thank you too all right check out andy
bubby's kitchen and garden on social
media and online at nannybubby.com we
also want to thank chapman automotive
for sponsoring this great segment
jason